well I can speak now to somebody who has
experienced firsthand some of the issues
in the UK's housing system and has since
become one of the country's most
prominent housing activists Croatia 20bo
it's great to have you on the program
and it was last year that we last fight
wasn't it it was um and Croatia is
someone who has the ear of government
you always in and out meeting people and
just just to introduce yourself to
viewers who might not be familiar with
yourself and the kind of campaigning you
do why did you end up being drawn into
this kind of activism well I started off
well I was I live in social housing and
I was living in poor quality social
housing with my sisters and my dad and
we were complaining to our landlord at
the time who just simply didn't listen
my dad became ill with cancer passed
away in those conditions and I had to
turn to social media in order to
disgrace my landlord not only my
landlord but other social housing
tenants landlords to into carrying out
necessary works and I know you're the
sort of person who is always amplifying
the voices of other people who are
currently living in these conditions but
just by the conditions that you and your
family will be in I mean damp mold
cockroaches mice we had a kitchen that
was nearly 100 years old poor security
we had lights filled with water you name
it I mean the list goes on and since
then I've been contacted by people in
social housing but also the private
sector too living in slum conditions in
a lot of cases whilst paying
extortionate rents I mean we know around
3.2 million people have said in the
private sector they have lived at some
point in um disrepair I think it's
really important to talk to people like
yourself actually because I do think
that there is a tendency in the
Westminster bubble whether it's
journalists politicians you name it for
people to reflect on their own
experiences right and actually that's
not always the norm and what people are
actually experiencing as you say like
across the country
what do you make of what the comments do
today do you think it's going to help I
definitely think it's going to help I
mean it's a long time coming people have
been asking and begging for um changes
and regulation the renters Reform Bill
for the private sector for a very very
long time so it's very
um welcomed especially with the ban on
no fault evictions that's something
people have campaigned on for so long
and just the idea of tenants being
evicted with no reason in a lot of cases
I mean for shelter for example there was
a hundred and forty three percent
increase in no fault evictions in the
last year alone so that just goes to
show how big of a problem it is and the
introduction of an ombudsman service for
example I mean with the scrap of no
thought eviction that doesn't mean that
landlords can't still evict tenants I
wanted to make that clear because I
think there has been some confusion what
it means is they have to have a valid
reason in order to do so having said
that with this legislation I definitely
think at the moment there are current
loopholes for example yes we're
scrapping section 21 but what we're
seeing is landlords can still evict
tenants for example if they want to move
a family member in or if they default on
their rental payments now what can
happen in this situation with bad
landlords they can then choose to up the
rent for example make it so unaffordable
tenants default and then a victim that
way or for example just say they're
going to move a family member in and
then the tenants have to have to move
out so the government definitely needs
to tighten up these loopholes to make
sure if landlords are evicting tenants
they're for the right reason and they're
honest about it you made the points
about funding yes as well and say that
there needs to be funding for
enforcement for this to work
um absolutely I mean that's my biggest
point I think it's all good and well
having this all written on paper and
having this bill discussed in Parliament
but fundamentally what we're relying on
in order to regulate this is local
authorities now with local authorities
we've seen them underfunded over the
last 13 years massively we've seen the
state of social housing run by some
local authorities and now what we're
asking is for them to manage 2 2.2
million landlords too I think the
biggest challenge for Michael Gove now
is um whether or not he can get the
funding to do so if the department for
leveling up doesn't have it then he has
to go to the chancellor and prime
minister and convince them that that is
the right decision to make just a bit
more widely as well it feels that
there's a big debate going on in Western
about house building and whether or not
it should be on the Green Belt whether
or not local people's concern should be
overridden what's your take on that from
what I've seen as a campaigner over the
last two years and the conditions people
are having to live in the rates of
homelessness people in temporary
accommodation
um I understand people's concerns
especially about the green belt but
simply we have a crisis here and a
crisis that has existed for decades we
need more homes if that means
unfortunately that we we have to build
input on pockets in the green belt then
I absolutely think we need to because
what is that other alternative we need
more homes fundamentally and then just a
bit more what it is about on the cost of
living
um it always shocks me when I look at
rental inflation right and also the
percentage of people's pay packets that
they end up spending on rent what is
going on in the private rental sector do
you think people are really really
struggling I mean I've spoken to
um tenants that I have to borrow off
their kids because they simply cannot
afford on their wages to pay for their
rent bills fuel bills and everything
else on top of that we've seen how much
food for example has gone up and um they
are really really struggling at the
moment I think what is kind of ironic
for me is the fact that government is
talking about home ownership and pushing
home ownership whilst we're in a cost of
living crisis and people are struggling
to pay their rents and rents especially
in London are currently unaffordable so
many in terms of one bedroom for example
one thousand pounds per month is their
average if people can't afford to save
how does the government expect them to
get on the ladder and especially during
a cost of living crisis too when people
are struggling that's the issue you need
to or they need to be dealing with is
bottom-up approach not top down and once
you make of Labor's sort of policies on
it do you have optimism I guess yes I
mean it's really really interesting I
think from both parties to see them
talking about housing for a long time I
don't think it's been discussed enough I
think housing is becoming very very
prominent and will be huge at the next
general election whether or not they are
going to make the right decisions and
focus on the the things that people are
calling for most
um is still up for a debate I think but
I really really hope they do listen to
the people if they're going to create
well-informed policies they need to be
informed by people affected currently by
the current situations